welcome to this video playing Barry ton
very torn from oops from Finland three
get a modern defense proved this type of
game don't play that often but it very
often leads to interesting plane and can
be shipped here maybe I can switch to to
e5 type of setup originally I was
thinking more along with c 6-r ok I can
go here maybe get them get the bishop
yeah probably alone but I can I can also
attack the center now that that looks
like a nice position get some influence
in the center
a five that's nice now you cannot really
secure his Bishop anymore I will get
that and I also have a better central
control Saudi takes c6 was certainly not
a move I needed to be afraid of
yeah I was thinking that this might be
an idea okay use use the center I mean
those bonds should open should advance
okay take care take care who won 97 97
attending a 5 or 95 let's Bishop g5
though can also just take it I mean this
is the simple solution playing for the
bishop pal maybe do that take here and
take the bishop or Bishop Bishop takes I
think it's not really good i will get c2
at the end now here
okay this was the keep it simple
solution but not a bad one getting this
play here and okay this is the sea can
do but now the other bishop is coming to
d5 under staff has left some pressure
before look before now maybe okay to be
five or where exactly look you form I
don't have such a very convenient square
maybe Brooke before wasn't ideal I try
to correct that 94 would be seven it's
not repeating it does not don't tell me
you thinking is better in this position
this would be really funny okay
so now I can play the root to f8
activate it okay you can take the bishop
pair now but okay I have then then it
just corrects my pawn structure nicely
and I have I have all these weak points
to attack a 5 p-2 yeah if is dropping
already I can check but just here this
is this is the easiest really the
easiest all the way here now this ruckus
is not this rook is a bit a bit annoying
nectar very active piece yeah okay just
push it all the way to a 3 he needs to
attend to that
there's also age three hanging with his
x-ray of the rook on the third and I
always have rupee eight to cover the
weakness in okay Bishop g7 maybe maybe
can play a we should be form here
thought rook fa it would be nice winning
a temple
nope okay he's still quite active so
it's not clear that I'm I'm winning this
this easily if at all rook be some
time was not easy at all really not I
mean maybe it's it's just just my
stupidity but I don't see a win I really
don't check
it should be for as the smaller sister
move look here it's not really working
check
playing this trying to keep at least a
draw in hand because with that little
time I can easily be that I screw it up
the thought right now we can even take
them to don't believe it what the [ __ ] I
mean I creature check check check check
check check check check game draw and
how can you not win this I mean now yeah
okay I don't know just allowed far too
much counter play him just need to trade
this bloody rook just trade one rook and
this game is over simply over Roxy 5 vs
is just just so easy yeah yeah yeah this
is this is completely completely over i
get i get to the second rank here
quickly i'm just playing like a total
idiot in this position and I mean it's
thought it is that it's took it's
unbelievable that he's not repeating
moves but ok and here yeah this is all
fine this is this is best play really I
just need to play rook c5 ok this is
also all winning everything but it is so
it is starting to get tricky push it
before was also better rooks it towards
minus 60 k guarantee it starts it starts
to get somewhat somewhat murky yeah
tough tough to play now it's tough to
play now
look f2a a that's what the chapter wants
to do this is just equal now this is an
equation check check yeah this is also
noting that white can can really win
probably we're not in 18 seconds yeah
but I mean it's just disappointing if
you if you see a series of moves like
this yeah then he deliberately goes into
this really really bad end game and
avoiding repetition of moves which was
funny I would have avoided it of course
myself but he did this and he are not
winning is really unforgivable now this
is especially simple with Roxy file I
was even a head on the clock boom
alright thanks for watching